let's bring it out let's bring up the  desolate line go ahead sorry  so it's it's collection system yes this  is uh you can just see that evil taken  energy boiling from the top of their  heads  yep here's our typo and they've  accessorized with one of our new strike  uniques on the back so there's a taken  effect weapons as well they look like  taking weapons but they operate like  human weapons mm-hmm and where and they  can get that from a strike from the new  winters run okay okay cool and do we  have do we have the emot-- that goes  along with this armor set yeah so when  you finish collecting the set oh my look  at them you unlock yeah the taking  jitter emo  all right thank you very much Guardians  you